LEON WEINBERG: Leon
Weinberg is the name.
I was born in Poland in 1925.
That made me--
I was 13 years old
when the war broke out.
Well, my life in Poland
before the war was--
I guess, was as normal
as anybody could
picture, a young Jewish boy from
a middle-income family growing
up in big city.
I was born in Lodz, which is one
of the biggest city in Poland.
I went to a Hebrew school,
which is a, uh, not a cheder,
a Hebrew school.
And when the war broke out,
I was just about finished
with my public Hebrew
school and ready to go on
to gymnasium, which is high
school, as I'm sure you know.
My family was my father, mother,
an older sister and a younger
sister, plus a very
large, larger family,
like aunts, uncles, which I--
I would guess amounted to about
maybe 200 people, or maybe
more.
And, uh, the, uh happy memories?
There were some--
School, kids, I was involved
in a lot of sports activities,
belonging to a sports club,
and playing table tennis,
soccer, like any other
normal, I would say, teenager.
And I remember exactly the
day when the Polish army
was leaving the city.
And the following day, the
Germans walked in, marched in.
In fact, at that time, us
kids, we stood on the streets,
we watched them come in,
not knowing what to expect.
And they looked to me like--
like Roman gladiators
with their--
with their Panzer
trucks, with the tanks,
marching through the city.
But it wasn't-- it
wasn't fear at that time.
It was just uncertainty.
We didn't know what to expect.
And it was always that
feeling, God will give,
something will happen.
Really nothing wrong will--
nothing's going to happen to us.
And just the first
few days of them
in the city of--
where I come from,
Lodz, were just about quiet.
When we found out
that the ghetto is
going to be formed in the city
of Lodz, which was that time,
the name was changed
to Litzmannstadt,
the German name for Lodz.
We were a few of the lucky ones.
Because the part of the
town where I lived in was,
was going to be the
part of the ghetto.
So we didn't have to
leave our apartment.
Uh, so we just stayed
where we were at.
Only thing, we had to
congest a little bit.
Because in about one week,
that whole part of town
swelled from a
population-- that part
of the city-- from a
population of probably,
maybe, 40,000 or 50,000
people to about 300,000.
And plus, every day,
all night, people
were brought in from the
outskirts of Lodz, too.
To know exactly how
many people there were?
I don't remember.
They would uh, uh, schlep
the uh, little wagons,
two wheeled wagons,
whatever that belonged them,
whatever they could save.
And how they settled in,
what happened to them, I--
I don't even know.
I know they, they slept in--
in schools and factories,
whatever they could--
they could push them in.
That's where the life in
ghetto started, where I spent--
I spent four years
in the Lodz ghetto.
And the only way in or out
was only for official people
bringing in the little food we
used to get from the outside.
And took a few, oh,
just a few months.
And we were organized in a
little small, self-ruling
government with Jewish
policemen, Jewish president.
Uh, I don't-- it was-- it was
a, a government run by Jews,
but naturally, overlooked
by the Germans.
Eh, they formed a
government of, of Jews,
and the head of the
government was--
they called him-- his
name was Rumkowski.
He happened to be a--
a-- before the war, as I, as I
was told, I never knew of him.
We worked in factories
producing clothing
for the German army,
shoes for them.
Food was given to you by
ration card, naturally.
And, naturally, the
food ration started
to get smaller and smaller.
Now, I don't know
if I could ever--
thinking back, what the type
of-- or the amount of food
we were getting was
unthinkable of now.
Because it got to a point--
and through the-- through the--
a year later, where we would
live on about eight ounces
of bread a day.
There was no butter.
It was margarine and a
couple ounces of sugar.
Like, meat, maybe, oh, couple
ounces of meat a month.
It was starvation.
It got to, I think-- in
1940, in the Lodz ghetto,
people were dying at the rate--
I don't have the exact figures.
But there was no more--
there were no more funerals.
At the beginning,
we had a funeral.
If someone died, there
was a real Jewish funeral.
But it got to a point afterwards
where people were taken away--
in the-- in the funeral carts,
with the horse and wagon,
naturally, 10, 12 in one--
in one wagon, piled up on top.
At that time, I--
the only thought, in
them days, was hunger.
You woke up in the
morning hungry.
And you went to sleep hungry.
Now, I don't know if
too many people realize
that when you are hungry,
there is nothing else
in the world which matters.
I was hungry for four years.
I never had my belly
full in four years.
I don't think any thought.
There's nothing else
when you're hungry, you--
you-- it gets to
a point where you
don't mind stealing
from your own sister,
from your own father.
There were-- there were
families, good people, friends
of mine, ourselves,
where everybody would
get their ration of bread.
Now, this is how people
get to be after--
after being hungry and being--
how do you say?
They're being degraded,
brought to a point
where they have no
more, uh, self-respect.
I would get up in the
middle of the night
and slice a piece of bread
off my sister's ration.
Now, I-- you would
never picture me--
and I can't even imagine
myself doing that now.
But it happened.
Parents, my parents will
never do that to me.
But us kids, we
would try to steal--
steal in a way or--
not thinking the
harm it will do.
But I don't know.
I don't even
remember the feeling.
There was just that--
there was just nothing else
in your mind but hungry.
I-- I-- often
thought that this got
to be a way of really getting
people to hate each other,
breaking up families
or breaking up,
or breaking down the morale of
people with not feeding them.
And no matter what
we try to do, it
was always one thought,
going home hungry,
going out and getting up
in the morning hungry.
And it's funny.
You know, I can't even think--
that's the only thing I hear.
Do you think of, is--
food?
Well, I stayed in the ghetto--
like I was saying, the-- the--
the labor camp started coming
in-- the labor commandos.
I did all kind of
work in the ghetto.
I was working at--
on-- on-- on buildings.
I was working as a--
as a taking, buildings down.
I was working
cleaning out toilets.
I was working.
You name it, I did
any kind of work.
And for some reason, I
was left in the ghetto--
I guess I was lucky
at that point,
though, because I'm
still alive now--
until 1944.
At that time, there
were camps already.
We didn't-- in fact, when
people were going out,
out of the ghetto,
with transports,
like 1,000 or 2,000
people at a time,
and that was-- that
probably was the worst.
The worst period of
my life, is the way
we were taken out of
the ghetto to work.
The way it happened, it would
happen any time in the day,
the middle of the night
or-- or in the daytime.
And the Sonderkommando,
what they call the Gestapo,
would come in.
A few officers with a couple
of dogs, and they would come.
In Europe, as you
know, the courtyards--
they would come in the
courtyard and blow the whistle.
And everyone in that
house, in that apartment,
has to come down to the--
to the yard.
And that would be
a selection, then.
And naturally, everyone--
I remember my mother,
she put a lot of
makeup on herself
to make herself
look good, young.
Because they would pick people.
You never knew who
they going to pick--
the young ones, the good-looking
ones, the healthy ones, the--
the sick ones.
So you just took a chance.
And they would just pick.
And every day, they would pick
a few people on the truck.
And they would disappear.
Never heard of them,
never knew what happened.
Rumors were they were taken
to either Treblinka, Ausch--
we didn't know about Auschwitz.
I myself didn't know the
first thing about Auschwitz.
Fact, I didn't knew
nothing what was
going on outside of the ghetto.
No news could come
into the ghetto.
To go on, eh, everyday life
in the ghetto, it would be--
I probably could
stay here for, for,
24 hours and about
little incidents,
what's, what was happening.
But the ghetto life was--
the only-- eh, with
all the hungry--
I was saying, all the hunger
and all the, the, the, the,
the, uh, the uh, you
know, uh, stealing,
because stealing was the--
to survive, you had to steal.
It got to a point, like I said,
you had to steal from your own.
You're not, you're not thinking
you're doing wrong because you
always made excuses, huh.
Maybe I'm young, I, I, you know.
It won't hurt my parents
if I steal a piece of bread
from them.
And after a while, you
know, it got, it got,
even if it bothered you,
and plenty of times I,
I, would just say--
it, it wasn't to a point
where I would hurt them.
I don't mean I stole from
them that I, that I, you know,
I made them starve, but it's--
I thought that a slice of bread
or a slice of butter would,
wouldn't hurt them, but
it'd make me feel better.
You ask me how it happened?
Now, I, I, I couldn't
honestly say why I did it,
though I love my parents,
and I, and I probably
just the thought that if they
ever go and disappear, or die,
or be killed scared me.
At any time where the Gestapo
would come and pick people,
I always hope nobody, I
hoped nobody from my family
would be taken away.
And for some reason,
until 1944, we
escaped every Aussiedlung
they called it.
In fact, I was the first one to
be taken away from my family.
When I left the ghetto,
the way it happened--
in fact, let me track back.
In 1942 it was the worst
time in the ghetto as far
as Aussiedlung.
At that time, we had a,
a children's hospital, eh
across the street from
us, from where we lived,
and I seen young infants,
just born, being thrown out
of the windows on trucks.
And every morning you find
out this one was taken away,
this one left the ghetto--
not left, I mean was taken away.
This one died.
And the family I've
had there, I mean,
it was a big family, a lot of
uncles and aunts and cousins.
It was getting
smaller and smaller.
In 1944-- I think
it was in March--
there was a knock at our door.
They came looking for me.
Why?
Uh, it was just
picked at random.
I was still young, healthy
to be taken to a labor camp,
and that's the last time I seen
my parents and my, my sisters.
I was scared, but never thought
of-- of being killed or--
I've, I, until that time I,
I did not know about any, uh,
crematoriums.
I didn't know about Auschwitz.
I didn't know.
I was taken with a
group of about, I
think it was, 700 people to,
to the town of, uh, Czestochowa
which was about, uh, oh, I would
say about 60 or 70 miles away
from, Lodz.
And there I was put to work in
a building, a German factory.
The Germans evacuated the whole
factory, naturally, with us,
and we were put, all of us--
there was-- that group I
was with was about 350.
We were put on a cattle
train and sent to Germany.
Now, that must have
been probably the worst
trip in my life, or the worst
experience I've ever had.
We spent seven days and seven
nights in a cattle train.
There was 80 people in
one, in one, in one wagon.
We took out at least 10
guys dead in that seven days
traveling.
We stopped.
We went from
Czestochowa, Poland.
The whole trip didn't
take that long,
but we were left on the railroad
tracks, on the side tracks,
for all days.
There were just pushing
us back and forth,
and seven days later, we
arrived in Buchenwald.
All we could see is from
the little windows look out
there, standing up, no
how to relieve yourself.
Everything had to be done
right there on the top of one
of each other.
When we slept, we had
to somehow squeeze in,
standing up, laying
down, or just leaning
on top of each other.
Now, that's got to be--
to think of it, I don't--
it was a nightmare.
When we got to Buchenwald, it
was, it was the end of 1944.
I spent, I spent about two
months in Buchenwald itself.
And then the same people
who came from that factory
in Czestochowa, that
all of us, the 350,
whatever was left
from that group,
were taken into a small
town by Buchenwald--
it was called Sonneberg--
where we were put to
work in a factory,
but the same factory which we
were building in back Poland.
There were quite a few
deaths every day because
of starvation, of beatings,
and, uh, uh, the, uh, only
hope we had then, we started
hearing rumors about the war
being close to an end.
That was-- that was already
in 1945, the beginning 1945.
But after five years,
from '39 till then, we
didn't believe any rumors
because we heard rumors
all along that the war's only
going to last for one day, two
day, two days, uh, one
month, two months, three
months, a year, two years,
and then it dragged on.
So at that time, there
was just no, no, no hope.
When we were taken to Sonneberg
in that, in that factory,
we had, uh--
we worked there for
about two months,
and then where the worst,
probably, period of our life
started, what they
called the march.
In April of 1945, we
knew that something
is happening with the
war, because we've
seen the first signs of--
of the war coming to an end.
We went on the march.
Took us seven days.
We slept in the open
in rain, and, and--
at the time it was--
we had a lot of
rain in that-- in,
in that part of the country.
We slept in-- one, one night,
I remember, they put us in--
in a schoolroom, where they
blocked off half of the room.
They put 300 people in
a room about the size,
maybe, twice of here.
And we slept on top of
each other all night.
And if anyone
stuck his head out,
there was a German
there with a--
with a whip.
And he would hit us in the head.
Then the following night,
we slept in a, a barn,
where a friend of mine
sticking his-- friend of mine,
say-- a fella I was in
camp with that time.
I didn't even remember
his name now--
stuck his head out.
And he was shot right there.
We had to start out again.
And from then on, we
marched again for two weeks.
Now, to describe that march
is really-- it's, it's, it's--
it's impossible.
We have-- naturally, we
didn't take our clothes off.
We marched, we marched,
we marched, for two weeks,
from one village to the other.
And then the-- we started
out, there was, uh, 350 of us.
But it-- when we--
when we were liberated-- in
fact, when we were liberated,
there was 200 of us left.
There was 150 killed
or died on that march.
I had-- I was with
a friend of mine,
who was a very good friend
of mine since childhood.
We were in camp together.
He was very sick.
And I guess I
saved his life by--
he was ready to commit suicide.
And I dragged him, with
somebody else's help.
And somehow, the war ended.
We were liberated, I saved him.
But while-- at that march, which
lasted for about three or two
and a half weeks, we had one--
we had one incident going
through a-- through a, a, uh--
through woods.
And it says 11 kilometers on it.
And that lieutenant
hollered out loud.
He says, if you don't
hurry up, the last one
gets shot every kilometer.
And sure he did that.
We didn't know
where we were going.
We were going from one
village into the other.
We just-- just like, like,
uh, like a merry-go-round.
And, uh, I don't know.
Before we know, I hear
shots and screaming.
And before we know, the
soldiers, the Germans,
have taken their hands up.
And that's how we--
and see there's
some American, uh,
couple tanks, and one truck,
a few American soldiers.
That's how we were liberated.
And it just a turn.
It happened just like that.
I thought that the joy
would be tremendous.
It wasn't.
They were just, just taken.
And first thing was just
get something to eat.
Was it bread, whatever?
And, uh, you know,
such a long time.
But I-- I don't
think I was happy.
I didn't dance from joy,
because I think we just--
I don't think we had
any feelings for dancing
or, or joy or smiling, anything.
We were just a very, very--
it was an existence.
That's all it was.
It wasn't-- I don't
think I could be happy.
I don't think I, I realized
what happened to me until--
I don't think I've ever.
I don't think I've ever
because too many things
happened afterwards--
you know, finding out
that my family's all gone
or getting used to
what things were.
I don't think I've ever been
very overjoyed that I stayed
alive, at that time, anyway.
It was just either way.
It happened, it happened.
I had a lot, I had, I
had very bad nightmares
uh, right after
the war, where I--
what happened after the
war, when I was liberated,
I went back to Poland
to look for my family.
So I didn't stay on in Germany.
I took the first train back.
And I went back to my
hometown, to my old apartment,
to my old house.
And naturally, that was my--
I broke down completely.
That's about the only
time I've broken down.
Uh, that was after,
right after the war.
And, uh, I spent a little
time there waiting for someone
to show up.
I thought maybe there's
someone still alive.
I spent about, uh, four or five
months after the war in Poland.
And then I went back to Germany.
And then living in the DP
camps for about three years.
Uh, there was a
period of life where,
where everything just-- we
tried to block everything out
of our mind.
It was just an
unnatural existence.
I've lived probably a
double-- a, a, a life before,
and a life now, which is
something entirely different
what we have now.
And I don't think I
can ever forget that.
I don't think I can ever, uh--
I did try the first years, you
know, after-- after the war.
I think I did try to erase
everything during to war.
And I-- in fact, I don't think
I would ever sit down and talk
about it if you
asked me that, uh--
let's see.
I came here in
1949, 30 years ago.
If you had approached
me, I wouldn't--
I don't think I would have.
And my memories were
much fresher then,
but I absolutely would
not talk about it.
But then later on, I just
started feeling different.
I started to, to, uh, look back.
And seeing, uh, that
things cannot be forgotten,
that you can't just,
uh, walk away from it,
or you can't just
say, this is it.
Uh, I can't, uh--
don't talk about it.
In fact, I was--
I was even ashamed
to talk about it.
I always thought that someone--
like, people say, oh, we
don't want to listen about it.
We don't want to hear about it.
We know all we have
to know about it.
But, uh, it's not like that.
I think I think about it more
now, maybe because I get older.
I'm getting mellow, to say.
I think a lot about it.
Too much, I think.